yeah speaking about having somebody back
cali panora off the bereavement list
welcome back alec uh you can see his
numbers in 12 starts this season five
and two with a very good 334 earned run
average this is 13th big league start
his sixth here at home he had his
three-game winning streak snapped in his
last start that was the one down in
washington when he allowed six earned
runs in three innings working to caesar
hernandez
good movement on that two saver calls
strike three obashett's been playing
some good shortstop he's working on 19
consecutive errorless games at shortstop
she's been rock solid in short lately
here's louise robert here's one two
beshette right on cue easy play two down
yeah he's been very aggressive
defensively he's been getting the good
hop and you're right it's just a matter
of time before he settles in 19
consecutive games uh airless at
shortstop that's that's something that
he's he can build on so here's eloy
menace we mentioned how hot he is here
comes inside and they jamming a little
slow roller to bow quickly to first and
that'll do it let's stop for alec manoa
those guys will be facing lance the
dance lin he's looking to get back on
the winning ways obviously to get back
and be able to get back into uh toronto
after that series in tampa but here's
his arsenal generally he's gonna throw
four seamers okay they're gonna cut
they're going to sink they're going to
do all kinds of things but it's
generally sinker he is going to just
throw fastballs and that's what i love
about lance bo bichette
swung out of his shoes on 0-1 cesar
makes the catch and one away 1-0 for
simeon
high in the air to left not deep
andrew vaughn is under it
and he makes the catch so two quick outs
here for lance lynn abreu way off the
line at first
struck him out on the cutter nice work
by lance lynn a very quick one two three
no score at the bottom of the second
inning and it's a full count
a rope to left andrew vaughan is on it
and one down there's a one hand little
reach across and he ends up with a ball
deep to left about 370 to left corey
dickerson scoreless tie bottom two
nice pitch strike three on the corner
really good right here by lance just
painting a corner so you saw that one
right there 93 you see not as much sink
but just stays right there and that's
also by design if he can sink a 90 mile
per hour sinker on the corner and show
him that he can get that pitch and then
all of a sudden he speeds him up with
93. it's not that much of a difference
but as a hitter it really gets on you
quick now 61 of the batteries he's
thrown two out of the first three
strikes
struck him out and off goes lance simeon
leads it off
to third johan is right on it one down
not a problem not a problem we got a guy
there man
for the out that was a scorching
screaming liner and he hit it right at
moncada
one away here in the fourth
chubby zamala the catcher one and two
swung on and missed the slider down and
away gets zavala what down boy he was
just messing with them he shook to the
fastball that he fouled off and then he
drops that thing on him and he had no
chance to hit that good spin good depth
on that breaking ball and zavala had no
chance he strikes out for a second time
fourth strike out of the ball game for
manilla and there's a breaking ball to
the outside corey dickerson was in
shallow and left and hernandez has
retired on one pitch oh two quick outs
here in the fifth you throw a lot of
strikes you'll get a lot of swings quite
a battle going on here here's another
long at bat runner goes 3-2 swinging a
miss he struck him out a brave finally
pushed aside by manoa after the two out
plunk the runner left at first base
middle of the fifth batter is andrew
vaughn all it takes is one swing to give
the white sox the lead here
that is through base hit andrew vaughan
monkatta scores and the socks are on the
board with three straight singles a
little small ball
works out in the sox favor here we've
hit a couple ground balls that have kind
of been seeing eye singles but it works
that was a 15-inning scoreless streak
for the sox that is over now when in
rome right if you can bounce them on
through do as the romans do that's right
worked out beautifully huh so two hat
now with a runner in scoring position
once again that'll bring vladimir
guerrero to the play 3-0
oh he got a good pitch to hit goes
around third here comes the throw it is
not in time for lance lynn left one over
the plate and vladi went right back up
the middle and the blue jays have tied
it up rbi for guerrero number 90. well
you knew that they were going to give
them the 3-0 green lights
you got your best hitter on the team you
got a guy in scoring position you're not
going to make him take so he gets the
3-0 green light it's right down the
middle we talked about getting a good
pitch to hit that's a good pitch to hit
right there and he bangs it right back
through the middle
earlier this season when he was hitting
really well with runners in scoring
position he was getting good pitches to
hit and he wasn't missing him he didn't
miss that one
and on top of that he's able to move
into scoring position on that throw to
the plate as his ball's not cut off
ladies gonna cash him in with that rbi
that's number 90 on the season and the
jays have come right back up so we're
going to the seventh alec manoa is
officially out adam simmers into the
game december pigeon toad kicks and
deals swinging a miss cesar hernandez
down swinging and now you got to deal
with abreu again with the runner at
first base
on the ground the shed second for one
back to first double clay good dig by
guerrero at first wasn't that sharply
hit but the infielders were patient they
knew they had some time and bloody digs
one out the oscars come out of the break
driving in big runs 36 rbi since the
break the most in the american league
back to the scoreboard that's going to
score run he's in there valera
swiped his hand over home plate before
kimbrough could get there the ball went
all the way back to the back stop blue
jays two white sox won two down nobody
on to the ninth
oh strike three that's the ball game
jordan romano
one two three in the ninth reece mcguire
with a pivotal infield hit to start the
eighth inning the blue jay scored a run
on a wild pitch in abuja's win game one
of this four game series as the ninth
inning comes to a close and the blue
chase pick up a 2-1 win
you